ahora quiero enseñarte que el algoritmo
que usamos siempre para multiplicar
números también se puede utilizar en el
sistema base 2 aunque de hecho se puede
utilizar en cualquier base no sólo en el
sistema base 10 al que estamos
acostumbrados pero vamos a multiplicar
en base 2 porque resulta que el sistema
base 2 es muy divertido a la hora de
multiplicar y muy fácil lo único que te
tienes que aprender son las tablas de
multiplicar pero únicamente hasta el 1
así es que solo tienes que saber que 0
por 0 es 0 0 por 1 es cero y uno por uno
es uno muy fácil de recordar no y listo
ya puedes multiplicar cualquier número
en el sistema binario entonces pues
vamos a hacer una de esas
multiplicaciones pero hagamos una que no
sabemos de memoria muy bien para poder
verificar el resultado por ejemplo
pondremos que te parece 9 x 5
a ver 9 cómo se escribe el 9 en sistema
binario pues tenemos que poner un 8
después no ponemos ningún 4 ningún 2 y
ponemos un 1 no entonces aquí estamos
sumando un 10 12 0 4 y 18 así es que
este sí es un 9 y ahora queremos
escribir 5 por lo que tenemos que poner
un 4 0 12 y 11 y queremos hacer esta
multiplicación así es que vamos a
utilizar el mismo algoritmo que
utilizaríamos si estos fueran números
del sistema decimal en lugar del sistema
binario pero espera sabéis que te toca
ponerle pausa y hacerlo tú solito y ya
después juntos vamos a ver si nos queda
9 por 5 45
muy bien suponiendo que ya le pusiste
pausa tenemos aquí que multiplicar estos
dos números del sistema binario
utilizando el mismo algoritmo de toda la
vida y ese algoritmo lo que nos dice es
que tomamos la primera cifra de este
número y la multiplicamos por todo este
número entonces tenemos uno por uno 1 1
por 0 0 1 por 0 0 1 por 1 1
ahora nos toca irnos al siguiente lugar
que en este caso es el lugar de los 12 y
como estamos multiplicando el segundo
lugar de este número tenemos que empezar
poniendo un 0 por aquí y ahora si 0 por
100 por 0 y 0 0 por 0 10 y 0 por 10
bueno desde el principio sabíamos que
esta hilera iba a ser una hilera de
puros ceros justo porque este número de
aquí es un cero pero de todas formas lo
hice para que vieras que realmente
estamos utilizando el mismo algoritmo
que usamos en el sistema decimal todos
los días
ahora tenemos que multiplicar esta cifra
por todo este número de aquí pero pues
esta cifra está en el lugar de los
cuatros entonces tenemos que poner ceros
hasta llegar al lugar de los cuatros y
ahora si uno por uno 1 1 por 0 0 1 por 0
0 y 1 por 1 1
bueno bueno ahora lo único que nos falta
es sumar estos renglones y ya vimos muy
bien cómo se hace eso en el vídeo pasado
de sumas en el sistema binario además de
que nos toca una suma su persencia no
aquí tenemos 1 0 0 1 0 0 0
0 0 1 1 1 0 0 1 0 0 0 y 1 pero si nos
hubiera tocado más unos por aquí la suma
hubiera sido un poco más interesante
pero como ya lo vimos en el vídeo pasado
sabemos muy bien cómo se hace el chiste
es que ya terminamos esta multiplicación
tenemos que esto por esto es este número
de aquí y haber este número es el 9
escrito en el sistema binario y este
número es el 5 escrito en el sistema
binario y 9 por 5 en algún momento nos
aprendimos las tablas de multiplicar y
sabemos que 9 por 5 es 45 entonces
queremos verificar que este número
binario en efecto es 45 que bueno esto
solo lo tenemos que hacer porque estamos
muy acostumbrados al sistema decimal si
nosotros pensáramos en sistema binario
nosotros veríamos esto y pensaríamos que
claro que está muy bien y no tendríamos
que estarlo
comparando con el sistema decimal pero
bueno vamos a checar que este número es
45 que por cierto el mismo nombre de 45
es un nombre basado en el sistema
decimal tal vez debería de llegar a
alguien e inventar nuevos nombres para
el sistema binario sería un proyecto muy
interesante pero bueno mientras tanto
vamos a ver si este número en efecto es
45 a ver este es el lugar de los unos
este es el lugar de los dos es el de los
cuatros el de los ochos 16 y 32 es
entonces para ver qué número en el
sistema decimal representa este número
binario
tenemos que sumar un 1 + 0 2 es 14 14 +
18 + 016 es más un 32 más un 32 y 14 832
si es 45